je m'appelle mars et je suis le chien le
plus veinard de new york grâce à elle
fait max et je dois y aller à ce soir
budget à plus tard mail à tous
salut les amis j'ai sonné sargis oui
j'ai plein de projets je vais rester
assis là et attendre que cathy rentrer à
la maison
oh elle me manque tellement 6 milliards
c'est une grande nouvelle
niles je te présente duke béton nouveau
petit frère way to et j'ai un gros
problème
cathy a ramené un psychopathe de la
fourrière j'ai même que de les voir par
terre comme un chien uk tentera de
cacher la ville ne gaspille ya urgence
trop mignon toi promène occupe toi fais
plus leur ai dit tu as fait ça nous
attendait
tout ça s'est ressenti papillon
tavoillot papillon mats a disparu il
faut leur trouver cas qui va être mort
d'inquiétude
on avait vraiment la belle vie je m'en
veux beaucoup oui moi aussi je t'en veux
beaucoup en vous sort de taule mais à
partir de maintenant vous voyez pour moi
c'est moi le boss
ok les gars vous n'avez rien vu ça
marche
fief cette ville je vais vous trouverez
votre ami il faut qu'on prenne le tunnel
secret ouais le tunnel de la mort qui
tue on va retrouver notre chemin on est
les descendants du via blue
pendant la flers ancestrale ravi de vous
rencontrer et c'est pour ça qu'on sera
vite rentrer chez nous
c'est pas là bas qu'on habite la galère
comme des dettes soit bien sage des
renards